brothers and sisters on this most holy
night in which our Lord Jesus
Christ passed from death to life
the church invites its children scattered throughout the
world to gather to watch and
pray we
will see the Lord's Easter
in listening to the word and in the
participation of the  sacraments The
Risen Christ will confirm in us the hope of
participating in his victory over
death and of living with him God the Father, let us
pray,
father who allowed your son,
you have communicated to us the living flame of your
van, bless
this new fire and through the
Easter holidays  let us mention the desire for
heaven so that we may be renewed in the spirit
We can add to the feast of the
Eternal Splendor for Christ our
Lord
Christ yesterday and today
beginning and end
Alpha
and tomorrow
to him belong the time
the centuries
to him the Glory and the power
for all the centuries of the  centuries
through your glorious Holy Wounds
it was possible and may Christ the Lord guard us
the light of Christ who rises Glorious
and dispel the darkness of the heart and of the
Spirit
behind
[Music]
Lumen Christie [
Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
toty you money If you hear me
friends centuries
[Music]
Lecce [
Music]
Heat [
right here [
Music]
claritate
[Music]
a name anyway they are
powerful men
[Music]
mercy in my mouth peace
here
don't be
deserving of
vitamins a number
you are sogrecare
[Music]
or dominus
thanks to sagamo stomino sky our
Christmas
[Music]
invisibilinte your partner
right here
[Music]
color
in which I can I hope they rise
Socci return
[Music] [
Music  ]
Edge caligine
Sincinorum secret
[Music]
in quotas
Cristo
Sapiens Victor
[Music] [
Music]
refugees if
T
on a Mira circa no
2 episode
[Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
little heart
[Music] big
solemn eyes
for human mystery Ste or to rest
[Music]
coagnino Soccer
here here
in peace [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[  Music]
stops us
Tutino Silverio
[Music]
and she meeting us Fermi
Louis
here regression Sapiens Ferri
man
ashes serene Yes yes
[Music]
brothers and sisters after the solemn beginning
of the vigil we listen with heart
insert a word of God
we meditate as in the  The ancient Covenant God
saved his people and in the
fullness of time he sent
his son to us as Redeemer. We pray
that God, our father, may bring
this work of salvation to completion.
Laughter at Easter
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
Bless  soul me odomino
you are svementa
R never summer while decoder
you can disguise
[Music]
which was a guest terrom
superstabilitotem on
non-tenant habits in centuries a
centuries I
abyss
[Music]
for Monte is abandoning
honey
here and I background you and you incur
[  Music]
for transibunt
[Music]
let us pray
O God
how do you Lavigne certain images and in a
more wonderful way you have renewed and
redeemed us let us resist with the strength
of the spirit the seduction of Sin
to reach eternal joy because
Christ our Lord
reading to a  book from Genesis
Nike elises
asked
Thomas
isacchi and go to you agimoria
when there is a race but has a
designated lockout after complaints will have a
sobrieli wood-fired levantown De pois extending
heavenly
[Music] [
Music]
truly world
[Music] subject to
out I hope
to have won
[Music]
out again
Or at least maybe inherited streamline
[Music]
of no
robot [
Music]
always
for hearts
amadextrix
not move
[Music]
every night
but
with age  you scroll me
a precore of me
[Music]
in super dear Romeo hours here in
heart [
Music]
men
hell
Neck Davis songton a video King
corruption
[Music] [Music
]
simile curse
[Music]
etc.
out
the  sphere
[Music]
we apply
God the Father of believers who
by extending to all men the gift of
filial adoption multiplies
throughout the earth and your children in the
Paschal sacrament of baptism fulfill
the promise made to Abraham to make him the
father of yours of the Nations
grant to your  people to respond
worthily to the Grace of your
call through Christ our Lord
lectura from the book of exes
and also I statis and the lord of homoises
porchessiga exclaiming to me
dialossi so Israel that he places himself in the
march
and you
raised tucaiato
estien de tumanos I would have the sea and
divide it
para que si so Reel passes a little
better than the sea put it dry
you areas that the sexios of steelen Y
enters in the Trust I must subtros i
mecurire de Gloria a Costa del Pharaon i
de todos e fersito the Sus carros i
desus kinetes
when I  you looked after Gloria in
Costa del Pharaon de Sus Carlos I
dezuskinetis
although march elankel of the lord that VAT
at the front of the army of Israel
I passed to Reta guard
also the column of nine that VAT
Adelante dejos seat eslassò I century
codetras always placing the camp
of the sexios and the camp of Israel
the cloud was dark the shadows
From the Noce
sinkelós pudi were proximarse and the one to the
other
Human being above the sea I the lord
issore pulled himself with a Fuerte Wind
of Este that I know plot Totò the nut
and the  Mars dried the seats said the sauas
entered the middle of the sea and the dry
and the sauas the sasian de Muraglia
adhered and izquierda
Los egyptios Los persichiero reenter
a trassedios and the middle of the Sea all the
diggers of the Pharaoh on scarros
isuschinettes
was Jana morning slime when
Mr. Mirò de La Whatever
site of the skcios seems to me the panic and
in the army and fiction
among you the Rodriguez de suskarros
assiendolos advance pessamente
of chiron
William santishell as long as Mr.
Lucio apurel with three I quote
luego of that lady moises
human extiendet over the sea  the
buellman
lasaurs on skyros isuschinettes
natural state
so that the sexios ensuida patch a
with the sauas
Ah yes rushed the mister
alosequicious and the mean of the Sea
the sauvas volvieron the scarros Los
kinetes i Toad lakersito of the Pharaoh who
has Vi entered the sea
New No  only if he saved
Mas losiko sirael they passed in dry
pormedio of the sea I enter the sauas to
siam de Muraglia to derecha and ischierda
to that the day saved the lord to Israel
of the power dekietto and Israel biolos
egyptios muertos and Loria del Mar
iOS the king the hand  powerful that the lord
has carried out against Los egyptios
itemò and the Pueblo to the lord cregliò him
and in Mr. Jem moises on siervo
to the lord
my love
[Music]
How many mos Domino
gloriosa in
magnified
sext
and
cometlift medium 10 cm
[Music]
fortitudominus
at  Factory
[Music]
dominus quasi
virpugnatore
dominus a name better
run shoot Every set exercise tu mejos
Project in mare
electi bellatore you are a submersi up in
Mario [
Music]
my love
[Music]
Dexter your Domine
magnifice in
Fortitudo di me
Dexter your Domine  so
[Music]
we see God who revealed in the light
in the new Covenant the meaning
of the ancient wonders so that the
Red Sea was the image of the
baptismal and precisely revealed front of
slavery to represent the Christian people
grants that all men through
faith  may they be made partakers of the privileges
of the children of Israel and may they be regenerated
by the gift of his spirit through Christ
our Lord
[Music]
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Music]
[Music] O
God  illuminate this Most Holy
Night with the glory of the Resurrection
of the Lord
revive in your church the spirit of
filial adoption because renewed
in body and soul we are always
faithful to your service for our
Lord Jesus Christ your son who God and
lives reigns with you  in the unity of the
Holy Spirit For ever and ever
from Theater simple to the Rollins
[Music] [
Music]
beatissime Pater announcement vobisco of a
magnum
quotes Alleluia
[Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause  ]
according to Matthew
[Music]
after the Sabbath at
dawn on the first day of the
week
[Music]
Mary of Magdala and the other Mary
went to visit the tomb
and behold there was a great earthquake
an angel of the Lord in fact
came down from  heaven
approached he
rolled the stone
and sat on it
his appearance was like lightning and his
dress white as snow
for the fear that the guards had of him
were shaken and remained like
love and you
The angel said to the women
don't be afraid I
know you are looking for Jesus the crucified
is not here he
has risen
In fact as he said
come
Look at the place where he was placed
quickly
go and tell his disciples
he has risen from the Dead
and behold he is preceding you in Galilee
[Music] you
will see him
[Music]
Behold, I told him, I
quickly abandoned the tomb with
fear and great joy.
The women ran to give the announcement to
his disciples
and behold,
Jesus came to meet them and said
Hello to you
and they came closer,
hugged his feet and adored him.
Then Jesus said to them
don't be afraid
go and tell my brothers that
they are going to Galilee they
will see me
verb he went come
[Music]
the night is about to end the
first lights of dawn come on When the women
set off towards the tomb of
Jesus
they advance  in some lost ones with a heart
torn by the pain for which the death that
took away the madman
but adding that they took that place and
seeing the empty tomb
they reverse the route they change direction
they abandon the tomb and run to
announce a new path to the disciples
Jesus has risen and  Easter awaits them in Galilee.
In the lives of these women, Easter took place.
Which means passage.
In fact, they pass from the mestogamino
towards the tomb to the joyful rush
towards the disciples. To tell them not only
that the Lord has risen
but that there is a goal to reach
immediately.  Galilee
the appointment with the risen one is there
The rebirth of the disciples the
resurrection of their heart passes through
Galilee
we too enter into this journey of the
disciples which goes from the tomb to
Galilee
the women says the Gospel went to
visit the tomb
they think that Jesus is there  in the place
of death and that everything is over forever
sometimes it also happens to us to think
that the joy of the encounter with Jesus
belongs to the past while in the
present we know above all about
sealed tombs
those of our disappointments
of our bitterness of our
trust
those of  there is nothing left to do
things will never change it is better to live
the day because there is no certainty about tomorrow
even if we have been gripped by
pain or taken by sadness
humiliated by sin embittered by
some failure or tormented by
some worry  we have
experienced the bitter taste of
tiredness and we have seen the
joy in our hearts fade away,
sometimes we have simply felt
the fatigue of carrying on with
everyday life,
tired of taking risks personally
in front of the rubber wall of a world
where the laws
of the smartest always seem to prevail  and of the strongest, at
other times we felt helpless,
discouraged in the face of the power of evil, the
conflicts that There were the relationships,
the logic of calculation and difference
that seem to govern society, the
cancer of corruption, there is so much
beyond the injustice  to the cold winds
of war
and perhaps we still found ourselves face to
face with death because it took away
the sweet presence of our loved ones or
because it grazed us in illness or
calamity and we easily
remained besieged by disillusionment and
the source dried up  of hope
so for these or other situations
each of us know our own
our paths stop in front of the
tombs and we remain motionless crying regretting ourselves
alone powerless to
repeat our whys
that chain of why
instead women at Easter don't remain
paralyzed  in front of a tomb But the
Gospel says he quickly abandoned the
tomb with fear and great joy both They ran
to give
the announcement to his disciples they bring the
news that will change the life
of history forever Christ is risen
at the same time they guard and
transmit  the Lord's recommendation
and his invitation are disciples to
go to Galilee because they will see him there
they are brothers and sisters we ask ourselves
today
What does it mean to go to Galilee
two things
on the one hand to leave the closing of the
cenacle to go to the region
inhabited by the Gentiles to leave the
hiding to open up to the mission to
escape from fear to walk towards
the future and to the other side
and this is very beautiful it means
returning to the origins
because it was precisely in Galilee that everything
began
there the Lord had met and called
the disciples for the first time So
going to Galilee  and return to the
original Grace and regain the memory that
regenerates hope,
the memory of the future with which we
have been marked by the risen Lord.
Here then is what the Lord's Easter does: it
pushes us to move forward to escape
from the sense of defeat, to roll away the
stone of the Sepulchers  in which we often
confine hope to looking with
confidence to the future because Christ has
risen and changed the direction of
history but to do this the Lord's Easter
takes us back to our past of
Grace and makes us go back to Galilee where
our history began  of love with
Jesus
Where was the first call
asks us to relive that moment, that
situation, that experience in
which we met the Lord,
we experienced his love and
we received a new and
luminous look at ourselves A look at
reality On the mystery  of life
brothers and sisters to rise again to
start again to resume the journey
We always need to return to
Galilee, that is, to go back not to an
ideal abstract Jesus but the living memory to the
concrete and pulsating memory of the first
encounter with him
Yes to walk we must remember to
have  hope we must nourish the
memory and this is the invitation remember and
walk if you recover your first love the
amazement and joy of the encounter with God you
will move forward
remember and walk remember
and walk remember your Galilee
and walk towards your Galilee and the  man
in whom you met Jesus in person
where for you he did not remain a
historical figure like others but
became the person of life, not a
distant God but the near God who
knows you more than anyone else and loves you more
than anyone else
brother  sister
remember the Galilee of your
Galilee in your call of that
word of God that in a precise moment
spoke to you about
that experience Strong in the spirit
of the greatest joy of forgiveness
approved after that confession of
that intense and unforgettable moment
of  prayer of that light that
came within and transformed your
life of that meeting of that
pilgrimage
everyone knows where their own Galilee
each of us knows their own
internal Resurrection theirs the
initial one the founding one the one that
changed things
we cannot  Leave it in the past, the
risen one invites us to go there for
Easter go there
remember your Galilee remember it
revive today
go back to that first meeting
Ask yourself how it was and when it was that
when it was
reconstructs the time and
place in context Try again  in the emotions and
sensations you relive in the colors and flavors
because you know and when you forgot
that first love and when you forgot
that first meeting that dust began to
settle on your heart
and you experienced sadness and as
for the disciples everything seemed without
perspective with a boulder to seal
hope
but today
brother sister the strength of Easter
invites you to roll away the boulders of
disappointment and distrust
the Lord expert in overturning the
tombstones of the Sin of fear
wants to illuminate your memory Holy I
no longer remember beautiful to make  current
that first meeting with him
remember and walk return to him
wrote the Grace of
God's resurrection in you
return to Galilee
return your Galilee
brothers and sisters let's follow Jesus to
Galilee
let's meet him and adore there where he
awaits each of us let's
revive the beauty of when  after having
discovered him alive we
proclaimed him lord of our life let's
return to Galilee to the Galilee of our
first love, everyone return to their own
Galilee, that of the first meeting
let's rise to a new life
brothers and sisters let's accompany
a soul with prayer and the glorious
hope of our catechumenals
Because God  father is omnipotent in his
great Mercy guide them to the source
of regeneration
[Music]
now money to you give me
earnings a day I do
n't know if
I
always arrive things
don't revolve around
[Music]
Mary Magdalene
Santa and Stefania
again  your mother
[Music]
How many
bases
always Martina
Holy veins
Rina
Colored French Saints
Nomads always Francesca
now tonight
[Music]
with the
colored stars with
us
they believe strong sex
[Music]
with death for you
they freed dreams
[  Music]
Almighty God the eternal manifest
your presence in the sacraments of your
great love and send the spirit of
adoption to recreate new children From the
baptismal font So that the action of
our humble Ministry may be stopped
effective by your power through Christ
our Lord
O God  permission of fragmentary essence you
work with the visible and Power The
wonders of salvation and in many
ways through the times you have prepared
the water your creature to be a sign of
baptism
from the beginning your spirit
hovered over the waters so that they contained
the strength in germ  to sanctify and even
in the flood you prefigured baptism
so that today, as then, the water would mark
the end of sin and the beginning of
new life,
you freed the children
of Abraham from slavery by making them pass
through the Red Sea so that they could be
images of the  future people of the
baptized finally in the fullness of
time your son baptized by
John in the water from Jordan was
consecrated by the holy spirit raised
on the cross he poured
blood and water from his side and after his
Resurrection he commanded the disciples go
proclaim the Gospel to everyone  the peoples
But you sartelli In the name of the Father of the
Son of the Holy Spirit
now father look with love at your church
and let flow for her the source of
baptism
in funds in this water By the work of the
Holy Spirit the grace of your only
son because with  the sacrament of
baptism let man made in your image
be washed from the stain of sin and
by the water and by the holy spirit be reborn
as a new creature
seems like a father to you in this water by the work
of your son and the power of the
Holy Spirit all those who  in it they will
receive baptism buried together
with Christ in death
with him they return to the extra life
he is God and reigns there with you in the unity
of the Holy Spirit For ever and
ever
[Music]
playing
[Music] [
Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
Dear ones, you
have asked for baptism and You have
spent a new time in your
preparation
now with confidence before the church and
together with all those who participate in
this Holy vigil before being
baptized make your profession of
faith
renounce Sin to  live in the
freedom of the children of God I renounce
give up the seduction of evil so as
not to let yourselves be dominated by sin renounce
Satan origin Sin I
renounce
Believe me God the Father almighty creator
of heaven and earth
believe in Jesus Christ his only son
our Lord who was born of the
Virgin Mary did not die  and was ready I had
been from the dead and be from the right hand of the
father
believe a holy spirit the holy
catholic church the communion of saints
transmission of sins the resurrection
of the flesh into eternal life
Wilhelmina you receive baptism
in the faith of the church which we all
together professed
I  I baptize you
In the name of the Father of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit amen
to Milan today for the baptism in the
faith of the church that we all
tried together yes desire
to Milan I baptize you In the name of the
Father of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
and the Don or received  testimonial Faith
of the church that we all
professed together Yes I want it
Elton I baptize you In the name of the Father
of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
ermelina you receive baptism in the
faith of the church that we all professed together
Yes I want it
emelina I baptize you In the name of
Father of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
you receive the baptism in the faith
of the church that we all
professed together Yes I want it
Veronica I baptize you In the name of the
Father of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
destiny you receive the baptism in the
faith of the church that all together
we have professed Yes I want to
destine it In the name of the Father of the
Son and of the Holy Spirit
Francis savier or receive baptism
in the faith of the church that all
together had professed Yes I want
sentences sand I must now In the name of the
Father of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
Omar Giovanni Battista or receive
baptism in the faith of the church that we
have all professed together Yes I
want it
Omar Giovanni Valtesta I am now
in the name of the Father of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit
dear brothers you have become a new
creature and are clothed with Christ
therefore receive the robe  white and
bring it without blemish to the
Tribunal of our Lord Jesus Christ
to have eternal life
bring godfathers and godmothers closer to
give the neophytes the symbol of
light
You have become light in Christ
always walk as Children of Light so that by
persevering in faith you can go to
meet lord  who comes with all the
Saints into the kingdom of heaven
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
dear neophytes
who in baptism have been reborn to the life
of the son of God and have become
members of Christ and of his
priestly people I now have the time to  receive the
gift of the Holy Spirit which on the day
of Pentecost was sent by the Lord
upon the apostles and which was communicated to the baptized by the Apostles
and his successors by their
successors.
Therefore you will receive according to the
promise the strength of the Holy Spirit
So that it may remain more perfectly  conformed
to Christ you can from the testimonies
of the passion at the Resurrection of the
Lord and become active members of the
church for the edification of the body of
Christ in faith and charity Dear
brothers, we pray to the
Almighty to found
the Holy Spirit on these neophytes who will confirm them
with riches  of his Gifts and with
the chrysmal anointing Make them fully
conformed to Christ his only son
of the almighty father of Our Lord
Jesus Christ who is regenerated these
children of yours by the water of the Holy Spirit
freeing them from sin the funds of
your Holy Spirit in them to  acrylic
spirit and Wisdom in law spirit of
counsel and Fortitude spirit of science
of Piety and fill them with the spirit of
your holy fear for Christ our
Lord May
the Seal of the Holy Spirit which is
given to you as a gift
be with you and with your spirit
in the Spirit  Holy One who is given to you
Peace be upon you and your spirit
Elton receives the seal of the
Holy Spirit who is given to you
amen Peace be upon you and your
spirit
receives the seal of the Holy Spirit
who is upon you  given as a gift
amen Peace be with you and with your
spirit
Veronica receives the seal of the
Holy Spirit who is given to you as a gift
amen Peace be with you with your
spirit
[Music]
of voice
receives the seal of the Holy Spirit
who gives you  is given as a gift
to me peace be with you with your spirit
[Music]
salver
receives and turn in the Holy Spirit
Who is is given to you as a gift
amen Peace be with you
[Music]
Omar John the Baptist receives the seal
of the Holy Spirit  that is given to you as a
gift
Peace be with you with your spirit
brothers and sisters we beseech God
Our Father that the Easter of his
son bring peace and salvation and life to all the earth
[Music]
push the church to announce with the
breath of the spirit  the Gospel of the
dead and risen Christ
[Music]
fills the Pope and all
the Shepherds of your flock with your grace
[Music]
makes the fruits of eternal life sprout in the
baptized whom he has grafted into Christ
who is true life
[Music]
make you new Christians  joyful and
courageous witnesses of faith
[Music]
Extinguish the hatred of the violent and open the
paths of forgiveness and peace
in dreams
free from oppression the hearts of
those who are afflicted in body and
spirit
[Music]
renew hope in the poor and
establish the justice of your kingdom
[Music]
grant us to communicate to the
Paschal mystery of Christ to be
one in him [
Music]
grant to the deceased the crown of Glory
promised by your son to the Faithful servants
[Music]
o father who in  Risen Christ you have
freed your children from the power of
death
welcome the prayer of the church
born from the wound and Love of the Cross
so that Christ our Lord
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
the brothers and sisters So that
my sacrifice may be pleasing to God the
Father  almighty
show
lords and the prayers of your people
Because the sacraments arising from the
Paschal mystery by your Grace
obtain for us eternal salvation through Christ
our Lord
the Lord be with you
in our other hearts
We give thanks to the Lord our God
and truly a good and just thing our
of holidays and sources of salvation
always proclaim your Glory oh
lord and above all to the
results on this night in which
our Christ and Easter sacrificed himself
and he the true lamb who took away the
sins of the world
and he who by dying destroyed death
and  by rising he gave us life again
through this mystery in the fullness of
Easter joy
humanity rejoices throughout the earth
and the hosts of Angels and Saints
endlessly sing the hymn of his
glory
[Music]
the true events Santos his father and  it is
right that every creator praises you
through your son Our Lord
Jesus Christ in the power of the Holy Spirit
make the universe live and sanctify
and continue to gather around you a
people who from East to West
offer sacrifice to your name  perfect
we pray humbly
sanctify and consecrate with your spirit
the gifts that we have presented to us so that
they become the body and blood of your
son Our Lord Jesus Christ who
commanded us to celebrate these
mysteries
and there on the night in which he was betrayed I
took the bread  I gave thanks to us with the
prayer of blessing
he broke it and gave it to his disciples and
said
take it and eat it in everyone this is
my body
offered as a sacrifice for you
[Music]
in the same way after having supper I took
the cup I gave thanks to us with
prayer  of blessing I would
say it to his disciples and he said
take it and drink it all of you this is the
cup of my blood for the new
eternal Covenant
poured for you and for everyone and in the
missions of the sins
done this in memory of me
[Music]
Mystery of Faith
[  Music]
lord
in the head of your mind
celebrating in memorial of the
redemptive passion of your son
of his wonderful Resurrection and
ascensions to heaven in the Church of
his coming in glory We offer you oh
father in return of Grace this
living and Holy sacrifice
look with love and recognize
in the offering of your church the sacrifice
sacrifices for our Redemption and to
us who nourish ourselves with the body and
blood of your son
give the fullness of the Holy Spirit
so that we become in Christ one
body and one Spirit may
the Holy Spirit make us
one  the offering for hernia of the welcome so that we
can obtain the promised kingdom with
your elect with the Blessed Virgin Mary
Mother of God Saint Joseph her husband
your Holy Apostles glorious Martyrs and
all the Saints our intercessors with
you
we pray to you oh father this sacrifice
of  our reconciliation
give peace and salvation to the whole world
confirm in faith and love your
pilgrim church on earth your
servant and our Pope Francis
the episcopal order the presbyters the
deacons and the people that you have redeemed
support in the Christian commitment the  your
children who today through the washing of
regeneration and the gift of the
Holy Spirit you have called to be part of your
people with your help may
always walk in newness of life
listen to the prayer of this family
that you have summoned to your presence
on the glorious night of  Resurrection
of Christ the Lord in his true body
reunite with you merciful father
all your children scattered everywhere
Welcome into your kingdom our
deceased brothers and sisters and all those who
have left this world at peace with you
grant us too to find ourselves
together to enjoy  forever of your
glory in Christ our Lord
through whom your God give to the world
every good
for Christ with Christ and in Christ
Today my almighty father and in the unity
of the Holy Spirit
every honor Glory forever and
ever
[Music]
obedient to the word Real Savior and
trained in his Divine teaching or
are we saying
[Music]
Feel that heaven moment
next to
[Music]
there is heaven [
Music]
I would like our heart I love you money and
who we will win
[Music]
Yes there  were and in the hearts Busto Arsizio
d'arte
[Music]
Deliver us oh gentlemen from all evils
Grant peace to our days
and with the help of your Mercy
we will always live free from sin and on the
hearts of every disturbance
in the church may the traveling
hope be fulfilled  and come our Savior
Jesus Christ
[Music]
Lord Jesus Christ who said to
your Apostles I leave you peace I give you
my peace
do not look at our sins But at the
Faith of your church
unity and peace According to your will
you who live and  reign forever and
ever
the peace of the Lord be always with you
in the spirit of the Risen Christ
Exchange the gift of peace
[Music]
children and children and dear ones
I turn to you who on this glorious night
are regenerated by the water and the Holy Spirit
for the  first time the bread of life and
the cup of salvation
the body and blood of Christ the Lord
make you always grow in his
friendship
and in communion with the whole church
are constants and viaticum of your
life and pledge of the eternal banquet of
heaven
Here is the  lamb of God
Behold he who takes away the sins of the
world
Blessed are those invited to the
lamb's supper
to the amount
now that I will be saved
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music  ]
Glory Glory to the Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music]
Thank you I [
always think
[Music]
ready outside
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
let's see
deep down in us oh gentlemen the spirit
of your charity  so that, satiated by the
Easter sacraments, we may live in harmony with each other
so that Christ our Lord
may be with you, may
the name of the Lord be blessed,
our help in the name of the Lord
may bless you, God almighty, Father, Son
and Holy Spirit
[Music] I, you, me
SAS hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [Applause
] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause] [Applause] [Applause]
[Applause] [Applause]
[Applause]